Is the world getting better or is
it on the verge of collapse?
Stefan Sagmeister emphatically
believes that things are looking up
and in the art exhibition "Now
Is Better" showcases a bold
new way to convince the world that
he's right.
He takes actual paintings from the
18th and 19th centuries,
disassembles them and creates
new works by juxtaposing them
with data visualizations
of just how much things have
improved since the good old days.
Some works chart the incredible
decline over the centuries and
deaths on the battlefield from
famine and from extreme weather
events, while others show how
much cheaper food and lighting have
become in real terms.
One piece documents the explosion
in the number of guitars per person
on the planet, an indicator of
growth in leisure and entertainment,
while another charts the persistent
belief that crime is always rising
despite its well-documented decline.
A heralded graphic designer who has
designed album covers for Jay-Z,
The Rolling Stones, and Lou Reed.
He's won two Grammy
Awards, including one for his design
of the Talking Heads boxset
"Once In a Lifetime."
Born in Austria in 1962,
he's called New York City home since
the 1990s, and he draws
on sources such as "Our World in
Data," Human Progress
and the work of Steven Pinker,
who has written the foreword to an
art book of the "Now Is Better"
series that's due out later
this year in a wide ranging
conversation.
Sagmeister tells me why it's so
important to acknowledge and defend
material progress.
Why art and commerce are not enemies
and what he loves about the new
world he's adopted as his homeland
and how that ties in to the "Now
is Better" project.
Stefan Sagmeister, Thanks for
talking to Reason.
Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
So give me the elevator pitch on the
"Now Is Better" show.
Well, it's basically comes
out of my interest
in long term thinking
because I discovered
that there are really two ways
to look at the world.
One is from a very short term
perspective.
What is happening right now, which
is basically what all media
looks at it.
And if you do that,
almost by definition,
everything looks bad
because things that
are going bad go bad
quickly.
Scandals, catastrophes and
so on. While many things that
develop well that develop
positively, do so very slowly
and don't really work
in our short news cycle.
But that's
really what the show is about,
to look at the world from a
long term perspective.
20 years, 50 years, 200
years. I think we have a couple of
pieces that are 500 years
and there, if you
take that point of view,
many, many things look very
positive.
Was there a moment where
you were like, Aha, this is
this is what my work is going to be
for the next few years?
There was. Well,
I was lucky enough to get one
of those residencies at the American
Academy in Rome.
And one evening I was sitting
next to a lawyer
who was the husband of one of the
residents artists, and he
told me that what we see in
Poland, in Hungary
and Brazil at the time
really means the end of modern
democracy. He was a highly educated
person, and I looked it up.
I went back to the studio that
night and quickly Googled
it. What's the story of this modern
democracy? When did it start?
And if you went back
200 years, there really was only
one in the United States.
I went back a hundred years
after World War I.
There were, I think, 18.
And now we have just
a good 80, I think 87
democracies that the U.N.
says they are democracies.
So it turned out that this
smart man
had really no idea of the road
that he lives in. But I discussed it
with other people and was
immediately surprised
how much pushback I would get
because, you know, specifically
there were certain people and in
this case it was mostly on the
political left who somehow
want to believe that things
are going down, that there
is some sort of an investment in
that.
What do you think that is?
I think if you're an activist, it
might be easier to get people
over to your cause if you can
tell them how bad things are.
And I think there's a truth to that.
Many of us being so
overwhelmed by all the negative
news that we get on a daily basis,
give up and say, Oh, this is so
terrible, we can do anything anyway.
One of the paintings that
you have is titled "Richer and
Poorer," and it shows
in 2020, 9%
of the global population was living
in poverty compared to in 1990.
35% of
the global population was living in
poverty.
But then you ask how
many people believe poverty has
gotten worse and 55%
of people believe that poverty
has gotten worse over the past 30
years. Only 12%
believe that it's gotten better,
which it has.
So are people misinformed
or do they want to believe that
they're living in a bad period?
I think it's a mix.
I think it's a it's
a mix of I don't believe that
the media is.
Inherently evil or.
Or is trying to mislead people?
No,
They believe what they're saying.
And they know specifically
now in the last 20
years since we have clickable
links.
They know what people like.
The media gives us what
we like, and we all
prefer negative news over positive
news. I am just
like everybody else.
I also do prefer
negativity and I
actually think to create
pieces that are positive
is somewhat more challenging
because they by
themselves tend to
be less interesting.
The vast majority
of pieces, when they have anything
to do with
commentary of life,
social commentary, anything
will be critical or negative.
One of the series of pieces
in the collection look at how
much richer we are.
One actually looks at global GDP
and how much richer the planet is
which is fascinating.
One painting is "Bright Lights:
Time worked for an hour of light,"
and in 1800 there
were 6 hours of work for an hour of
light. In 2000, it was 2
seconds, work for an hour of light.
You have another one about 3 hours
working a job.
And it's amazing that
not only has the amount of work you
have to do for a second of
light has come down,
but the amount that we work
is much less.
How do people respond when you say,
"Well, actually you're working a lot
less than your your father probably,
or your grandparents?"
On the work front, I
think there
was an interesting phenomena
going on right now in
France, you know, where you have all
these protests going on
against moving
the pension years up,
and I think that's a direct
result of
this information not being
part of our daily
discussion.
Because if everybody would
be aware that we
now live double
the amount of time than we did
100 years ago, then it's just
logical that we would have
to work a little bit more before
we can go into
our retirement.
You have a piece called "Artists,
Lawyers and Doctors" and this is
the number of artists, lawyers and
doctors in the U.S.
Artists 2.5 million.
Lawyers, 1.3 million.
Doctors 900,000.
Is it a sign of a good society that
there are more artists than doctors?
It's definitely the sign of a good
society that it would
be able to sustain
a very large group of people
that has very little function.
We can't do anything before
we'd have shelter, before we can't
breathe and eat.
And so all of these
other things, and specifically
the artistic impetus,
is only be able to even
to be pursued once
we have shelter.
And once we have
The cave paintings are of the
animals that hunters caught
so
Exactly
you can paint
after you've eaten, but probably not
before.
And they're done in a cave once you
are sheltered.
Right. Right.
Yeah.
And you have another piece, the
number of playable guitars
in the world, which has increased
massively. So that speaks
to the idea that it's a pretty good
world where a lot of
people are expressing themselves
creatively.
That's an indicator that we're doing
pretty well.
Yes. The numbers of the guitars
is absolutely
astonishing because it went
from a couple of hundreds of
decades ago to tens
of thousands now.
So, I mean, the increase
is just incredible.
Going in the other direction, you
have a painting that talks about
the decline in the number of deaths
from natural disasters,
which is also something that,
again, if you're I would say
if you're over 40, you should have
no problem realizing like when
you were younger, you would hear
all of these stories about, you
know, hundreds of thousands of
people starving to death or
dying because of earthquakes
or volcanic eruptions or tidal
waves. And you don't really hear
that very much anymore.
But we think the world
is getting worse on that scale.
Yes. Well, it's exactly
what we talked about in the
beginning. It's that there has never
been a news report about
there was no earthquake
in California today.
Right. So all the positive
things just go unreported.
But even the absolute number
of people dying went down.
It is a fraction of what it used to
be. And that's certainly true of
things like pandemics and what not.
So however bad COVID was,
the response was quicker and more
effective than the 1918
flu epidemic.
Yes, I always found it fascinating
that during COVID one of
the words that was
used the most in the media, also
in the New York Times was
"unprecedented.".
Right.
Even though the people
who wrote that nearly
had the knowledge that this
is not unprecedented, maybe
unprecedented this year, but for
sure, not unprecedented this
century, Right.
Where you had AIDS that killed
30 million people, you had the
Spanish flu was between
50 and 100 million people and so
on.
You know, a number of the pieces
talk about immigrants and
immigration being a positive thing.
You yourself are an immigrant from
Austria to New York.
You first came here in the late
eighties. You settled here
fully in the early nineties.
What drew you to New York and
how does that reflect
in your work?
Well, I came here first right
after high school.
It was a high school gift
from my brother in law.
It was in 81.
So New York was, from its
now perspective, in
a pretty bad shape.
I would say crime was incredibly
high, but it was
just fascinating to me.
Even though I was born in a very
pretty small town in Austria,
I was always attracted by
big places.
I think it's also a lovely
mix of American
friendliness, which might
be odd because, you know,
New York is not known as a friendly
city.
Exactly.
But ultimately it is
quite open.
And I haven't done a piece
of it yet, but I've just
come across and I checked it and
it seems to hold up.
I just came across data
that showed that refugees,
not immigrants, refugees
that have been in this country for
25 years or longer
have a 30% higher
income than the average American.
And with immigrants, okay, I believe
it. But the refugees,
it's pretty astonishing that
refugees in their lifetime,
not in the beginning when they come
here, but in their lifetime
would surpass
the locals.
I find that to be the strongest
indicator that there is
an American dream, that that is
a life that I've come across.
And I know it has been incredibly
fashionable to say that the American
dream is dead.
And even I feel
sort of like silly sitting
here are claiming otherwise.
But those numbers point in that
direction.
Your background is as a graphic
designer.
Yes.
Which is more functional than
you know, than art.
Right.
True. 100%.
Do you see a sharp distinction
that many artists or many critics
would draw between kind of
commercial art or instrumental
art and real art?
Is that a false dichotomy?
I can argue it both ways.
If people ask me, "What do you
call yourself?" I definitely am a
designer and the work that I'm doing
here, I would also see as
design work
simply because
I would say that there is a
functionality to it
and which I find pleasing.
But I also totally understand
that many artists would
not want any functionality
to their pieces.
That's the whole point of art,
right? It's that it resists
being used for some other purpose.
And I would say even there would
have to really say it's the
whole point of contemporary
art, because art
by itself, if you look at, has
historically, of course, also had
many functions.
Many of the most
famous artists in
the past did very functional
work. You know, Michelangelo
designed candlestick holders.
Leonardo obviously did
many, many other things.
There is no such thing as
pure functionality.
It's all on a scale.
Talk a little bit about your process
for the pieces in this exhibition.
Basically, you buy cheap
paintings from the 18th
and 19th centuries and then
you put data visualizations
over them.
It originally started with pieces
that we still had in the
attic, in the house that I grew up
with that came from my great
great grandfather's store, who was
an antique dealer in western
Austria. And the stuff that didn't
sell wound up still being
stored still to this very day.
So the first pieces really came from
there. And since then,
I'm by now, I think
connected to about
through the auction houses,
all of them in Central Europe,
mostly Austria.
So what do you show money or what do
you pay for a piece that you're
going to paint over?
I think they're all
for sure under €4,000,
which, you know, I'm kind of a
beneficiary of the fact
that specifically 19th
century art, but also 18th century
art is very much out
of the fashion right now.
What is the pleasure of painting
over, you know, a piece from the
early 19th century
with a data visualization that
shows how much better things have
gotten?
Well, we're not really painting
over. We're really basically
taking the piece apart.
We are plucking holes into
it and we are inserting
the new data.
So the piece, if you want,
is destroyed, which
I had given some
thoughts about meaning, ultimately,
I solved it for myself, thinking
that if somebody in
200 years takes my
work that they
found at tiny auction
houses and makes a new piece
out of it, I think I would be very
happy about it.
But the process really is
I buy these pieces at auction.
By then I've already had
received the photo, so
I ultimately try out designs
and these can be inspired
by the data.
They can be inspired by a color
scheme, they can be inspired
by form that can be inspired
by a composition.
They can be a reaction
on the existing piece.
But ultimately, by and
large, I'm trying
to go against the composition
that is existing because
that sort of seems to create
the kind of tension
that ultimately.
Makes a good new composition.
How much did you increase on
average? Just make it up if you have
to. You know, if the average
painting that you started with
cost €4,000,
what was the average that you were
selling it for?
How much did you increase the value?
I think it's probably times
two or three.
But of course, there's also
significant cost involved
in creating this.
You know, like there is an
incredible amount of
just hours that go into that, not
just myself or for my own, but
there's a whole team working on this
in the Brooklyn Navy Yard, there are
costs in renting the space,
all of that stuff.
So there is that.
But ultimately, I
actually try to keep
the price as low
as it's possible that it
still makes sense.
Yeah, I want this to be in
as many homes as possible.
That's the functionality of it,
because ultimately the goal and
in therefore really
it's embedded in the concept
that these things hang on somebody's
wall as a reminder
that what they just read on Twitter
doesn't mean it's the end of the
world.
You've worked with a number of very,
you know, globally known recording
artists like Lou Reed, like the
Talking Heads, like the Rolling
Stones.
And you did an album cover for The
Rolling Stones. Which album was that
again?
Bridges To Babylon.
Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, that's
like a platinum record.
What what does it feel like to
know that your images are going
out to, you know, a million people
or more?
Fantastic. You know, it's also
something that I love about design
is that it's a pretty
democratic way
of working where you know,
we did a Jay-Z cover where the first
one was 5 million for
the price of $20-25,
which I don't think there is
a publication in the art world
that reaches those kind of numbers.
I very much love the fact
that design tends to live
within our lives.
I see myself as a communication
designer more so than a graphic
designer. I think the challenge
specifically for somebody like
me is to make these
things.
Interesting enough.
That even though they're positive,
people will be engaged.
And, you know, that's the challenge.